Das ist quasi ein kleiner schritt für die menschheit aber ein riesiger sprung für die dänische raumfahrtindustrie obwohl industrie es sind amateure
raumfahrttechniker anfang august gelang es ihnen ihre selbst gebaute rakete in eine höhe von 600 kilometern zu befördern ein voller erfolg
vor allem wenn man bedenkt welche
materialien sie für den bau der rakete verwendet haben das glaubt wirklich niemand und auch ihr ziel ist verrückt der erste bemannte
amateur raumflug kriegs um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
4000 meter
5000 meter 6000 meter und mehr dann geht der fallschirm auf und die selbstgebaute nächste 2 rakete kehrt
kontrolliert zur erde zurück die dänischen raumfahrt amateure können ihr glück kaum fassen mehr als sechs kilometer
hoch hat es die rakete des hobby tüftler vereins copenhagen
software mittels also in die luft geschafft auch wenn das nur ein kleiner zwischenschritt zur verwirklichung ihrer
großen vision ist denn zukünftig wollen sie einen menschen ins all schicken als erste amateure
weltweit schon jetzt sind sie die ersten überhaupt weltweit die erfolgreich raketen bauen dazu einer der verantwortlichen techniker
jörgens gut es lief fantastisch nichts ging schief eigentlich erwarten wir dass etwas schief geht wenn wir einen staat haben aber diesmal klappte alles
vollständig perfekt und der veranstalter ergänzt das ist bei diesem testflug gar nicht mal so sehr um die höhe ging
vielmehr habe man wert darauf gelegt dass der antrieb mindestens
40 sekunden lang durchhalte die rakete gerade fliegen und die rakete auch wieder in der ostsee lande und den theoretischen berechnungen
der amateure hätte die raketen excel 2 sogar bis zu 15 kilometer hoch fliegen können der start gelang von einer schwimmenden
plattform auf der ostsee nahm sputnik eine genehmigung für den staat vom land aus wäre wohl kaum vorstellbar gewesen der start der
178 kilogramm schweren rakete war übrigens um eine woche verlegt worden
denn wegen der schlimmen waldbrände in schweden konnten die behörden nicht für die sicherheit des luftraums garantieren nach dem öffnen des fallschirms fiel die rakete
kontrolliert ins meer zurück und war so sicher in der nähe der dänischen ostseeinsel bornholm
gelandet die raumfahrt amateure wie sie sich selbst nennen benutzen für den bau ihrer rakete übrigens durchaus
kurioses material nämlich das was man auch für herkömmliche drucker und
kaffeemaschinen verwendet dazu vereinssprecher matt wilson wir zeigen dass man mit herkömmlichen
material
unglaublich weit kommen kann denn der bau von raketen seien nicht nur etwas für staaten die über millionen budgets verfügen
schon seit jahren arbeiten sie auf ihr
langfrist ziel hin und zwar mit bis zu 60 freiwilligen schon seit 2011
basteln sie an raketen und raumkapseln und haben bereits fünf stück fertig gestellt und ebenfalls von einem schiff in der ostsee
abgeschossen excel 1 hatten sie vor zwei jahren also 2016 gestartet doch das weit weniger erfolgreich sie kamen nur
1500 meter hoch dann ging ihr der treibstoff aus die idee geht übrigens auch peter madsen
zurück er wurde ja wegen des mordes an kim wohl auf seinem auto zu lebenslanger haft verurteilt 2008 hatte er das projekt
gegründet
2014 kam es zum streit mit den anderen
mitgliedern und er verließ den verein auch wenn es jetzt einen großen erfolg gehabt
wenn man mal ehrlich ist wird die vision der dänischen tüftler wahrscheinlich noch etwas länger
reines wunschdenken bleiben denn die grenze zwischen erdatmosphäre und weltraum die liegt in
100 kilometern höhe dennoch zeigt die tests flug allemal das hobby tüftler mit kleinen mitteln
großartiges auf die beine stellen können und ihr könnt den
raketenbau direkt hier auf youtube folgen einfach hier draufklicken und den kanal der copenhagen
service abonnieren und wenn er kein video zum thema astronomie
und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxee auf youtube und wertet sogar vorab über neue videos von mir
informiert einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch dortigen zeitenwende in allen neue falcon 9 version also bis dann
bleibt dran